All right, so, this is what I came up with.
First and foremost, we need to set this display method on the projects object.
So, using dot notation, I simply set the property display on
the project's object and set it equal to a function.
This function is using a for in loop, for projects in projects.projects.
Inside the projects object,
we have an array of projects, also called, well, projects.
Like we said in the hint,
we need to start with HTMLprojectStart to create a new project entry.
Then you'll see a set of steps where we're appending the title.
The dates, the description, and images to this project entry last element.
Remember, HTMLprojectStart is creating an element with the class project entry,
and we want to grab the last one every time we work through this list.
Following the same strategies we've been using in this class,
we'll be appending each of these elements to project-entry:last, and
when we're done, we should see a nice beautiful project section.